heute wir haben jetzt acht produkte im
einkaufsladen für 237 euro schreibt
gerne in die kommentare was würdet ihr
euch bestellen wenn ihr einfach so
spontan frei bestellung machen könnte
[Musik]
hey was geht ab jetzt gekommen bei geht
wird schon mal daumen nach oben bei
einem neuen video ja doch ich hoffe
natürlich es geht euch gut heute habe
ich nach sehr langer zeit mal wieder
marie dabei denn die dachten wir wären
nicht mehr zusammen haben nämlich
gefragt
auf jeden fall macht sich offenbar aus
einem bestimmten gründen wird nämlich es
gibt was umsonst ja kann ich eigentlich
direkt bei am anfang sagen das video ist
nicht meine idee das habe ich schon mal
gesehen und zwar bei der julia putics
video von ihr völlig euch gerne in der
beschreibung
bei mir ist es nämlich so ich habe jetzt
in letzter zeit auch schon das eine oder
andere amazon bestellt video gemacht und
ich habe jeden monat so einen kleinen
freibetrag dann könnte ich halt bei
amazon bestellen und sachen aus cotton
also muss man auch kein geheimnis drum
machen das haben glaube ich mehrere
jugend linie 18 jahren
genau 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 14 wenn
ihr die letzten amazon - noch nicht
gesehen habt dann checkt auf jeden fall
die letzten amazon videos ab verliere
ich euch am ende oder ihr schaut einfach
selber nach und ich hätte dir mal
schnell die heutige video idee also du
hast ja schon gesagt oder du hast mich
einmal gefragt kannst du mir nicht mals
und halloween kostüm bestellen dann was
ich dafür kein geld ausgeben das ist hat
sich ja ist ja auch so nein nur bei
alexis umsonst und ich habe eine kleine
tür dich also dieser echt geil ich
wollte mit meinem bruder erst machen
aber er hatte keine lust und zwar hast
du gleich fünf minuten zeit ich glaube
dass mit meinem
und darfst hier bei amazon bestellen was
du willst also gut man muss ganz ehrlich
sagen du kannst jetzt nicht hingehen und
your iphone macbook weil irgendwann ist
das er aufgebrochen
aber du kannst sie eigentlich schon
bestellen was du willst du hast uns halt
die zeit wird nicht gestoppt ich kann
dir nicht vereinbaren würde die absolut
keine frage du musst alles selber machen
und ich gucke dazu was du dir bestellst
ich hoffe du hast du schon gedanken dazu
gemacht
ein bisschen schauen ja gern mein
halloween also leute ganz wichtig kurze
unterbrechungen und zwar habe ich
zusammen mit tutor auf seinem kanal ein
neues video gedreht wir haben uns
gerettet
die waadt gemacht wir haben's gebettelt
mit den earth day tag der link dazu ist
ganz oben die beschreibung und ganz
wichtig wenn ihr bock habt sind teils zu
gewinnen müsst ihr einfach in die
kommentare schreiben hier unter diesem
video hashtag nerv warum ist haben wollt
gibt noch nach oben ab und nicht
vergessen und checkt auf jeden fall das
video ab und jetzt geht es weiter
ich habe hier mein macbook mitgebracht
der nach 22 akku hat ich habe mir das
reicht mir geben suchst du danach weil
ich nun vielleicht überlegt wie eine
kaffeemaschine darzulegen
leute wir sind jetzt hier auf amazon
also fünf minuten nicht mehr und nicht
weniger
du kannst dir aussuchen was du möchtest
bis 500 euro einschließlich an also mehr
geht nicht
ja es ist ja auch eine menge ich meine
fini tief deswegen fand ich es cool wenn
jetzt nicht irgendwie eine sache für 400
euro nimmt und dann ab 2014 euro sondern
halt wirklich mehrere sachen also so
viel wie möglich ist eigentlich würde
ich mal schätzen
am coolsten dann würde ich sagen die
stoppuhr auf die plätze kleiner trommel
wird
[Musik]
fertig
sie fängt sofort an und gibt ein calvin
klein unter hosentasche die handel
keinen klar dass also gefangen direkt
mal an mit wenn jetzt könnt ihr meine
anliegen auf jeden fall 114 euro für
achte scheiße bis 500 euro
[Musik]
also ich glaube sie hat sich hier für
die würde ich definitiv nicht gut ist
sie ja die kostet auch noch 183
aber das macht die würde ich neben dem
die das ding ist alles was jetzt von dem
gutschein ball hat ist ja für mich weg
deswegen ist es am coolsten oder für
mich am besten mit möglichst wenig herum
kommt also wir haben 150 sekunden
diese kann ich einfach sagen ich glaube
die schon ausverkauft das soll bald eine
minute ist schon rum
ich bleibe ich natürlich hier auch die
zahl 1 was hast du denn als nächstes so
3 eur 91
die finde ich aber hässlich dachte mir
eine geschichte erzählen
es war einmal es war einmal ein mädchen
wenn man zahlt also weit mehr sein es
war ein
was sagen es war einmal ein mädchen an
halloween also das würde ich nicht mehr
was gefällt mir gerade dann guck mal
hier ist ein richtiger fehler drin es
war einmal ein mädchen und die durfte
sich alles bestellen auf mazztv de palma
zu halten und die lüfte sich alles
bestellen was sie möchte auf formation
ja wahrscheinlich dass in den
kommentaren alex halt einfach ich fresse
aber leute taktik ruppert ich will mir
erst mal hier die kundenrezensionen
durchlesen damit wir auch sicher gehen
kannst das ist wirklich das richtige ist
bei 150 euro station auf den kopf
gehauen
berlin jetzt bei zwei minuten wenn es so
weitergeht sind die 200 euro 500 euro
gleich weg da wurde mal hier was soll
das werden uns wurde gesagt ich habe
gerade mein halloween-kostüm ach so
abstimmen wollte sie auch halloween
artikeln von alexis reine black sind
anti finde ich gut
alex ist gut leider
und ganz wichtig also mein plan ist dass
du dann auch die sache nochmal wir
zusammen aus taxi wir dann wieder zu
stellen und dass wir dann halt
vorstellen und mal gucken was du dir
wirklich gestellt hast dann würde ich
eventuell so eine folge könnte ich auch
nochmal mit meinem bruder machen
sorry dass ich jetzt so viel wie ihr
lover aber ist ja sonst langweilig was
hast du jetzt noch reinkommen wenn ihr
darauf hoffen dass mit meinem bruder
dann lass gerne mal daumen nach oben da
hey zwei kontaktlosen ja ich habe dann
möchte ich besser 593 euro
da bin ich wirklich schon bauchschmerzen
portemonnaie damen klein ja also ich
muss ja sagen ich muss ja sagen die
elcom aber jetzt nicht für nicht so
sonst heißt es mir keine 50 euro ok
geologisch ja aber geht's nicht
was wollt ihr jetzt noch sagen gerne
also du hast noch eineinhalb minuten
gleich ja du hast doch die lücke die
union ist doch super sie ist also die
pflicht
also ich möchte das ist ja wirklich
dies ist hier wirklich eine menge geld
es ist wirklich eine menge geld wir
haben noch eine minute und 15 sekunden
also praktisch kein sport jetzt 34
guck dir mal das an 34 guck mal die hat
sowieso richtig schlechte rezensionen
die würde ich mir nicht bestellen
stell dir weil du mich einfach mal
ablenken lässt 227 euro
heute gibt's nämlich übel bei mir eine
werbung mehr drin ist
also obwohl das video geht
wahrscheinlich gar nichts unterstreicht
übrigens an den scheiben alex das video
geht ja schon wieder über zehn minuten
damit die werbung schalten kannst das
denken ist die meisten videos von mir
die über zehn minuten gehen werden nicht
auf zehn minuten sorry dass ich das
jetzt hier sagen kannst mir aber zu
hören übrigens sehr wichtig die werde
ich auf zehn minuten gestreckt sondern
auch zehn minuten gekürzt zum beispiel
die amazonen videos weil wenn die 16
minuten gehen finde ich das echt lang
dann mache ich lieber halt zehn minuten
so wir haben ein paar sekunden glaube
ich du hast jetzt endspurt vielleicht
hast du das was ist das denn
ja und zehn neun acht ich hoffe dass
passwörter auf jeden fall entsteht jetzt
und das ist das letzte
was ist das ford starb fünf minuten sind
rum ich mich eine art maria cosmetics
controlling palette preis konnte mit
exakt meine heute wir haben jetzt acht
produkte im einkaufswagen für 237 euro
das ist jetzt schreibt gern meine
kommentare was würdet ihr euch bestellen
wenn ihr einfach so spontan frei
bestellung machen könnte und vielleicht
habe keine ahnung was ich mir gerade
frisch linke gestellt haben wir haben
zusammengefasst die mac pro palette du
weißt nicht was das ist
wir haben die apple iphone hülle die ich
absolut überteuert verlebte 34 euro wir
haben einfach für dich ich dachte auch
an halloween angeschrieben macht es mich
wenn leute seid ihr dafür dass ich
einmal in einem video so mittag den sind
einsätze der mitte so was von beiden wir
haben die kontaktlisten für insgesamt 30
euro ist für mich viel zu viel
wir haben die herunter damen stulpen
abends dürfte für 12 99 wir haben dieses
halloween halloween kostüm das ist nicht
nur gelungen eigentlich oder doch ich
zeige ja ich habe es mir dann ein
und wir haben diese bugs und eine tasche
114 euro freut mich was hier immer weil
diesen taschen wollte ist ja ganz toll
ich glaube die meisten frauen kaufen
sich lieber eine tasche für 500 euro
anstatt all meinen urlaub zu fahren
damit wir jetzt hier noch keiner sagen
kann ja ja du kannst das doch ehrlich
zur kasse gehen amazon ist mal wieder
schnell unterwegs
hallo und musste das machen wir jetzt
ist der staub wieder unter so leute
vielen dank ihre bestellung wird
bearbeitet
also jetzt mal bitte hier ein dankeschön
aber wenn ich da starte schon richtig
großes dankeschön der schöne alte leute
ich würde sagen die sachen wenn sie da
sind packen wir nochmal zusammen aus vor
allem die halloween sachen ist ja sehr
aktuell alles von bis zu 720 naturbad
außerdem hätten die uno das heißt das
video dazu kommt die sind freitag oder
diesem sonntag online freut euch drauf
wie schon gesagt wenn ihr bock hab das
jetzt auch noch mit meinem bruder mache
mal gucken was der nicht so bestellen
würde last nach oben da schaut euch
gerne das video von der julia und
schreibt in die kommentare
verstecken um einmal die nach data ist
zu gewinnen dann habe ich mir das video
zusammen mit tutor gemacht mit den link
auf und in der video beschreibung und ja
das war es von mir hier wird sagen wir
sehen uns mit so wenig größer so ja auf
jeden fall bundes tut mir leid dass ich
heute ich hoffentlich viel geladen ist
sonst auch nicht nur meine art